so I think fluency is a sense of total
comfort in the language total comfort of
getting your you know ideas across even
if you have some mistakes that you
always make and you're never ever going
to correct it doesn't matter and and
it's essentially understanding what the
other person is saying not having to say
how big your pardon beg your part so to
be comfortable in the language natural
in the language
but it doesn't mean that you're perfect
it doesn't mean it certainly doesn't
mean that you have no accent
uh you can be identifiable as a
foreigner you can make typical
English-speaking mistakes typical
Japanese speaking mistakes but if you're
like totally
able to express yourself you understand
what the other person is saying as far
as I'm concerned you're fluent
and I think that's a lot more reasonable
goal than having zero acts and never
making a mistake it doesn't exist like
that not one person in a thousand is
gonna achieve that